the very first Oscars that I can
remember
my first Oscars memory was when I was
seven I was young around eight nine
years old I think when I was 12 years
old I remember the speeches uh the
energy of the night thank you thank you
thank you it was just the kind of
fascination with the event itself I was
more focused on the beautiful gowns
growing up in the midwest the Academy
Awards were always a really huge event
in our house it was something that my
mom enjoyed my dad enjoyed seeing all
the glamor all the movie stars all the
great filmmakers well that would have
been on a little
13 inch black and white television in
those days while my mother sat behind me
and said it's a sweep I remember Al
Pacino winning Al Pacino instead of
women's is a very prominent film that
won called The Godfather Godfather every
award no matter who won she would say
it's a sweep nothing against Gandhi but
I was really sad when E.T did not win
best picture my first Oscar moment was
in Sweden being a kid hearing about the
Oscars but never being able to see it so
I'm from Norway and the Oscars happens
like in the middle of the night my mom
let me have my friends stay overnight
and wake up in the middle of the night
and make us popcorn and snacks and watch
the Oscars when I was 16 I succeeded in
watching it for the first time until
early morning which was very difficult
because I had to be in school two and a
half hours later that year the Oscars
C-3PO and R2D2 came out on stage and
I've never forgotten and remember Celine
Dion wearing the Heart of the Ocean as
she sang I mean she sang her lungs out
for that song another one that it was
David and even presenting on Oscar when
a naked guy appear running in the uh on
stage
that was
it was sort of an obsession in our house
with the Streaker epidemic I was a kid
and I'm like
what is that